en el vídeo anterior encontramos esta
ecuación diferencial que describe un
circuito lc y ahora vamos a resolver
este circuito de segundo orden la
técnica que usaremos aquí es la misma
que nos sirvió para resolver las
ecuaciones diferenciales de primer orden
necesitamos una función de iu que haga
que toda esta ecuación sea verdadera y
vamos a hacerlo proponiendo una y
sustituyendo la en la ecuación y ver si
funciona si funciona ganamos si no
tendremos que pensar en otra cosa y
seguiremos haciendo esto hasta que lo
resolvamos sabiendo lo que conocemos
sobre derivadas y viendo esta ecuación
me puedo imaginar una posible solución
aquí tenemos dos términos cuya suma
tiene que ser igual a cero durante todo
el tiempo vamos a escribir esta ecuación
así quitamos esta constante de acá aquí
lo que tenemos es un factor de escala
que multiplica a y que tiene que
restarse por completo a la segunda
derivada de esta ahí así que estos dos
términos tienen que lucir muy similares
el tiempo y conozco una función cuyas
derivadas lucen como con lo que
iniciamos y es la función exponencial
así que voy a suponer que y dt tiene la
forma de una constante por la
exponencial de st la exponencial del
tiempo por algún otro factor k es un
parámetro ajustable y es la amplitud nos
va a decir qué tan grande es la señal y
qué es ese es está en el exponente junto
con t y sabemos que al momento de tomar
la exponencial de cualquier cosa lo que
sea que tengamos aquí arriba no debe
tener unidades lo que significa que esta
multiplicación no debe tener unidades y
si es está multiplicando a t entonces
ese tendrá unidades de 1 entre tiempo
así que ese es una frecuencia y en
particular va a ser una frecuencia en
radiales van a ser radiales por segundo
así que a ese le llamaremos la
frecuencia natural
ahora vamos a sustituir está ahí en
nuestra ecuación para ver si se cumple
sustituimos y directamente aquí y
necesitamos la segunda derivada de y así
que primero debemos encontrar la primera
derivada del y es igual a del dt de acá
por el ala st y esto va a ser igual acá
por s por el ala st así que sigue siendo
una exponencial y ahora necesitamos la
segunda derivada así que vamos a tomar
la derivada de esto que acabamos de
encontrar la segunda derivada de y con
respecto al tiempo es igual a la
derivada con respecto al tiempo de
nuestra primera derivada que es s por
cada x a la sct
aquí baja otra s por lo que tenemos s al
cuadrado por k por el ala st ya tenemos
nuestra segunda derivada que vamos a
poner aquí la sustituimos y tenemos s al
cuadrado porque x
a la st 1 / l c porque por el ala st
igual a 0 vamos a sacar el factor común
que tenemos aquí que es acá y ala st que
multiplica a s al cuadrado más 1 entre l
c
todo esto igual a cero aquí cuántos
parámetros ajustables tenemos pues
tenemos acá y a ese nada más tenemos a
estos dos se le dice son constantes que
son los valores de nuestro circuito así
que necesitamos encontrar los valores de
acá y de ese para que esta ecuación sea
igual a cero cada podría ser cero por lo
que nuestra amplitud sería igual a cero
lo que significa que si ponemos nada en
el circuito pues también tendremos nada
como resultado lo que es totalmente
aburrido esta no es una solución
interesante
a la ese porte se vuelve cero alguna vez
y algo nunca se vuelve cero
si yo dejara que te llegara a más
infinito y ese fuera un número negativo
entonces si es a la ese porte sería cero
pero si hay que esperar que éste se
vuelve a infinito pues hay que esperar
muchísimo tiempo y no queremos esperar
tanto así que la solución interesante es
s al cuadrado más 1 / l x c igual a cero
y a esta ecuación le llamamos la
ecuación característica veamos qué
sucede cuando tratamos de resolver esto
el primer paso es tener s al cuadrado
igual a menos 1 entre l por c o s igual
a la raíz cuadrada de menos 1 entre l
porsche y vean lo que tenemos aquí la
raíz cuadrada de un número negativo que
va a suceder aquí pues nuestra respuesta
va a ser un número imaginario podemos
escribir esto como la raíz cuadrada de
menos 1 por la raíz cuadrada de uno
entre el porsche y esto me va a dar dos
respuestas a la primera respuesta le
vamos a llamar ese 1 y va a ser igual a
jota que es nuestro número imaginario
que es la raíz cuadrada de menos 1 para
los ingenieros eléctricos multiplicado
por la raíz cuadrada de 1 entre l
porsche y nuestra respuesta s 2 es el
negativo de esto igual a menos jota por
raíz cuadrada de uno entre l porsche
estas son dos posibles soluciones a
nuestra ecuación diferencial y vamos a
darle un sobrenombre a esta expresión de
aquí ya que no quiero escribir tanto
vamos a llamar omega 0 a la raíz
cuadrada de 1 entre l por c
esta es la letra griega o mega pero en
minúscula esta es la omega mayúscula la
que usamos para homs pero la omega
minúscula se usa para esta variable así
que puedo decir que ese 1 es igual a j
omega 0 positivo y s2 es igual a menos j
omega 0
vamos a usar esta anotación pero
recuerden que es solamente una
sustitución tenemos dos raíces
diferentes que pueden hacer que nuestra
ecuación diferencial sea 0 así que vamos
a combinarlas para tener una solución
para y decimos que es igual y vamos a
usar una combinación de estas respuestas
ya que no sabemos cuál de ellas es
incluso podrían ser ambas podrían estar
superpuestas y justo para esto sirve la
superposición
ahora también necesitaremos dos
constantes esto es igual a cada uno por
el a la s 1 t mascados por el ala s 2 t
es igual a cada uno por el sustituimos
la s 1 por más j omega 0 t
cada dos por el ala menos j omega 0 t y
esta es mi solución propuesta y
encontramos dos valores para nuestra s y
ahora necesitamos encontrar estas dos
constantes en el siguiente vídeo
usaremos las condiciones iniciales para
encontrar los valores de k1 y k2